it was just a few weeks ago that the
ACLU took the state of Tennessee to
federal court and lost horribly the ACLU
tried to get the six circuit court of
appeal to uh strike down a law that
banned child genital mutilation
specifically the ACLU argue that there's
a constitutional right for parents to
sterilize and castrate their own
children and this backfired
spectacularly for the ACLU as we
discussed on this show at the time and
uh as today uh mutilating children in
the name of gender affirming care
remains illegal in Tennessee so they
failed and these procedures have been
halted now given that recent history you
might think that the ACLU would think
twice before it filed yet another agenda
driven lawsuit against Tennessee you'd
assume that at the very least they'd
ensure that they had an airtight case to
make sure that uh uh that you know they
that that everything's fine before they
ever step foot in another courthouse in
the state that's what they would do if
they were a serious civil liberties
organization that took the law seriously
but the ACLU isn't a serious serious
civil liberties organization and it
hasn't been one for some time now it
resembles a cult
and like so many other so-called liberal
institutions that people used to take
seriously it is basically a leftwing
cult and if there's one thing we know
about cultist it's that they don't have
any shame whatsoever they're not
deterred by failure or humiliation they
just press on at all costs to promote
their ideology Come What May so this
week predictably enough the ACLU boldly
announced that it's once again suing the
state of Tennessee in this time they're
not seeking to castrate children instead
they're fighting for the right of HIV
infected prostitutes to knowingly spread
their infection to their clients yes
really that that's that's why they want
a court to strike down Tennessee's
statute on aggravated prostitution now
I'll get to the aclu's arguments for
this in a moment but just to be crystal
clear about what the ACLU ACLU is
objecting to here uh I I want to I want
to read the Tennessee statute on
aggravated prostitution this is what
they don't like this is what they're
suing against here it is quote a person
commits aggravated prostitution when
knowing that such person is in infected
with HIV the person engages in sexual
activity as a business or is an intimate
uh or is an inmate in a house of
prostitution or loyers in a public place
for the purpose of being hired to engage
in sexual activity aggravated
prostitution is a class C felony now
unless you're a prostitute who wants to
knowingly infect other people with HIV
it's hard to see what conceivable
problem you could have with a law like
that prostitution is already illegal in
Tennessee for obvious reasons and all
this law does is attach extra penalties
if you engage in prostitution when you
know that you have a deadly highly
transmissible disease that causes a
progressive failure of the human immune
system so that seems pretty reasonable
right but for more than a year activists
in Tennessee have been campaigning
against this law in the interest of full
disclosure and because it's honestly
pretty amusing um here are their
arguments this is a professor from the
University of Memphis named Robin Lenin
Dearing and here's what she says watch
can you tell me a little bit more about
your research and the main
takeaways yes the biggest thing that
people don't understand is that the HIV
criminal laws do not require people to
actually transmit HIV at least that's
the way it is here in Tennessee in fact
they don't even have to have physical
contact for example we have two laws one
of them is aggravated prostitution and
with this particular particular felony
law all they have to do is get into an
undercover police officer's car or agree
to um talk to someone who is an
undercover police officer and they are
arrested so number one it doesn't mean
that you've transmitted HIV and number
two the people that are arrested are
usually financially insecure perhaps
homeless living on the street they have
no money to fight the
charges okay so the first argument you
just heard is that people can be
arrested for aggravated prostitution
even if they don't actually succeed in
transmitting HIV this is a tremendous
Injustice according to this professor at
the University of Memphis notice how she
describes her hypothetical scenario you
know she says all you need to do is get
into an undercover police officer's car
um and if you happen to quote agree to
talk to someone who's undercover police
officer then the cops will book you for
aggravated
prostitution now in case you haven't
guessed uh she she's she's leaving
something out here which is that the law
requires that you knowingly have HIV
when you get into that undercover car
and then knowingly offer sex to that
undercover police officer so yes you
don't you don't actually have to
successfully transmit HIV but if you try
to then that's still a crime which means
that it's it's pretty much like any
other felony like if you successfully
commit a felony then that's a crime if
you try to in most cases but you fail
that's still a crime if you try to kill
someone even if you don't succeed in
killing them it is still a
crime and I think for most people that's
not hard to
grasp and all of this you know these
these seem like important details but
the professor with two last names and
pink glasses somehow forgot to mention
them by the way this professor Robin
Lenin Dearing builds herself as a social
work educator who uses quote an
anti-oppressive practice framework an
intersectional perspective to increase
awareness of social injustices so if you
send your child to the University of
Memphis that's what you're paying for in
fact if you pay taxes in the state of
Tennessee that's what you're paying for
because it's a public institution but
let's get back to this professor's other
argument she also says that many people
arrested under this prostitution law
happen to be financially insecure
they're often homeless and quote have no
money to fight the charges of course
this isn't an argument at all it makes
absolutely no sense to legalize immoral
and dangerous Behavior because most
people engaging in this immoral and
dangerous Behavior also happen to be
poor I mean if that's the standard then
we can't be too far from legalizing
murder because the vast majority of
people who commit murder aren't exactly
Rich it'd be one thing if you know it
were just one Lefty faculty member at
the University of Memphis who talked
like this but this is now a common view
on the left in fact the reasoning gets
even worse when it announc the lawsuit
um against Tennessee over this
aggravated prostitution law the ACLU
made this argument quote breaking we're
suing Tennessee for their aggravated
prostitution statute that targets people
with HIV with harsh punishment and
lifetime Sex Offender Registration this
law is unconstitutional and
disproportionately affects black and
transgender women now I'll read the rest
of their statement in a second but let's
pause for just a moment um they're
saying that the law targets people with
HIV just like that Professor they're
ignoring the fact that the law only
applies to prostitutes with HIV who know
they have the
virus Okay so so unless we're saying
that everybody with HIV is a hooker then
it does not Target people with HIV it
targets prostitutes who have a deadly
virus who are knowingly attempting to
spread it the October 15th tax deadline
has just passed I know many of you might
be dreading the stress of filing your
taxes filing your taxes can be a long
excruciating process but if you fail to
file you'll start to pile penalties on
your tax debt and that's why you need to
check out tax Network USA the team at
tax Network USA has a track record of
success they have reduced tax debt for
numerous clients totaling over $1
billion whether you're looking at a
$10,000 or a $1 million tax debt they
can help you with a settlement doesn't
matter if you haven't filed in one year
five years even a Whole Decade tax
Network USA is equipped to secure the
best settlement for you the expert
attorneys and tax professionals at tax
Network USA can help resolve all tax
cases no matter how they started don't
let tax debt control your life any
longer take the first step toward
resolving your tax issues by visiting
tax Network
usa.com Walsh that's tax Network
usa.com Walsh today but ACLU they're not
the only ones um playing this game
here's a statement on this law from the
executive director of out Memphis a
woman named Molly Quinn quote this
statute solely targets people because of
their HIV status and keeps them in
cycles of poverty while posing
absolutely zero benefit to public health
and safety yeah preventing the spread of
HIV has zero benefit to Public Health
this is how pretty much every
institution on the left argues now they
don't just lie they also omit every
relevant detail to push their agenda the
other part about that statement from the
ACLU is revealing uh in ways that the
ACLU probably didn't intend they say the
law disproportionately affects black and
transgender women meaning men now two
things about that first of all you know
it's fine for a law to
disproportionately affect certain groups
as long as that's not the purpose of the
law right if if you're passing a law
with the intent of uh you know
oppressing a certain racial group well
not that's not good that's that's you
can't do that that's
unconstitutional but if the law applies
to
everyone then its disproportionate
impact is irrelevant again laws against
murder you would argue
disproportionately affect black
communities um because violent crime is
is more common in the black community it
doesn't make the law
unconstitutional in fact here's the
thing laws against any crime crime will
disproportionately impact those who want
to do that crime that's the way laws
work laws against stealing
disproportionately impact those who want
to steal it's just that's the way it
goes but the really interesting thing
about the ACLU statement is that they're
claiming that by and large uh black men
are the demographic group that's
knowingly spreading HIV within their
communities they're not saying the
police are enforcing this law in some
racist way they're not claiming that
that that the cops are fabricating
evidence or anything like that they're
saying that black men are the ones who
are doing
this and and they're supposed to be the
anti-racist side I
suppose um now here's what aslu says
Tennessee should do instead of this
here's what they said instead of
criminalizing HIV which
disproportionately targets people who
are already socially and financially
marginalized lawmakers should invest in
evidence-based public health support for
people with HIV Tennessee we'll see you
in court again there's the arrogance
from an organization that just lost
badly to Tennessee in court first they
tell voters in Tennessee that they can't
ban child castration now they're telling
voters that they don't have a right to
punish prostitutes for knowingly
transmitting HIV in their
states instead they're saying Tennessee
should adopt evidence-based public
health support which is double speak
that means precisely nothing I mean to
the extent that you can Divine any
meaning from those words it actually
sounds a lot like what Tennessee is
already doing jailing people who
knowingly spread HIV is evidence-based
public health support it's maybe the
most logical most evidence-based method
imaginable when it comes to dealing with
this problem what theu is really saying
is is something that um you know the
left hates to admit outright but it's
also something they believe very
strongly and this is what it all comes
down to and we've seen this kind of
thing in States not just in Tennessee
where they whether it's prostitutes or
anybody else they're trying to
decriminalize The Knowing intentional
spread of
HIV and in all those cases what what
that is really rooted in is the left
belief that the highest good is to
follow your sexual impulses all the time
everywhere with no limitations you know
they value unbridled irresponsible sex
whatever the consequences might be if
you conceive a child in the process then
just kill the child they say if you get
HIV no big deal if you spread HIV no big
deal just keep on having sex and
spreading HIV so that everyone else can
join in the fun I mean this is Hedonism
it's what the left values far more than
the so-called minority community
communities that they claim to care so
much about they would they would rather
encourage prostitution and contribute to
the spread of HIV in these communities
than actually do something to help them
and without any kind of higher guiding
purpose or belief in any higher power
leftists are fixated entirely on Raw
sensory
pleasure they're as prideful and self
assured as everyone else who settled on
that purpose in life throughout all of
human history they're not unique or
special that's why like the heess of the
past soon enough they'll be defeated
dead and
forgotten and that is why the ACLU and
its many left-wing supporters who
desperately want black men with HIV to
prostitute themselves and spread HIV are
today canceled hey YouTube thanks for
listening to the show if you'd like
access to my full show with no ads you
should go to dailywire.com and use promo
code Walsh to get two months free on all
annual plans see you there